get set for tony dungy the hall of famer
on loan from nbc sports who joins us
from tampa good morning tony
hey d.p it looks like you guys are
having a little too much fun there i'm
watching during the break and a lot of
activity going on
oh yeah bet you got a nice little setup
you got some sunshine there
you got uh is that a solarium that you
have there
that is the kind of the fenced in area
around the pool
and i have to be outside we got seven
kids who are homeschooling i promise you
it's a lot quieter outside
than it is all right i want to play
something for you we had dean blandino
on yesterday and he of course was used
to be the head of
nfl officials and we were talking about
sky judge and the role of sky
judge and what it's going to play what
it's going to look like feel like with
the upcoming season is it just for the
preseason of the regular season but
here's my question for dean blandino and
his
answer how often would you contact the
officials
on the field that that we didn't know
about when when you're
from the home office can you talk about
this now of how often you'd actually do
that
sure look it would happen from time to
time i mean we had
we had a plan in place especially during
the post season
where if there was something and this
was going to be a break
glass in case of emergency situation
right this was going to be
the saints rams this was going to be
something significant we're not talking
about something in the first quarter
this had end of game impact that we we
had a code word
i would get involved i would communicate
to the referee
we would get the officials together they
would have a conversation and we'd
figure it out
with the help of the video right that's
not something that would happen very
often
it would be in that isolated instance
where if this is a play
that we're going to talk about for years
to come let's get it right now even if
it's not within
within the realm of the rule and let's
deal with it now didn't happen very
often but but we did have that in place
okay so that's dean blandino we reached
out to the nfl the nfl said we have no
comment but then through
through a source i was told the
following tony
dean blandino was describing how he
approached certain situations
now this is he when he was in that role
and
that the rule book permits
some of this but not what he's talking
about penalty enforcement the proper
down
spot of foul game clock dean blandino
was talking about if i'm looking at
something that needs to be changed
i'm going to do this now he wasn't there
for the rams and the saints he's talking
about extreme circumstances
are you surprised at all by you know
that dean blandino was doing this
even though that's not in the rule book
no i'm not surprised
and i have a lot of respect for dean i
thought he did his job as well
as you could do it uh there's a lot of
pressure there
and my only i guess problem with that
would be
how do i know that a play in the first
quarter isn't monumental yeah
i would have wanted you to step in in
the first quarter if there was a huge
mistake that might
impacted my career and my team's chance
to win a super bowl so
that that to me is the whole problem
with this sky judge thing
who says what play is going to be
critical how do we know looking back
what the big play was are we going to
get involved with everything and every
little detail on every play
i just i never have been a big fan of
replay
um and i think this is just one of those
reasons why
well the sky judge i just don't know how
much authority he has
can he can he see something
and it might be away from the play where
there's a holding call
or you know a personal foul and then all
of a sudden he
calls down and then is he going to
dictate what's going on in the field or
is it the other way around
right and and to me that's the problem
with it everybody thinks oh well we've
got this guy who can see everything and
he's got all these cameras and he's
sitting there and
and he can see what actually happened
yeah then he can call down but what
happens if there's something else on
that plate uh do
i look at the whole play do i look at
everything hey yeah the guy did really
catch the ball but they had offensive
holding or there was it should have been
a false start call
we we had a play rams uh kansas city
huge play
everybody on tv saw that it was a false
start the play
was allowed to go it was a touchdown for
the rams uh are you bringing that back
because you happen to see it there's
just too many things that go on during
the course of the game
to say we're going to stop a play
because we think it's critical
as a former coach are you glad that the
past interference
replay is going away
i i just don't see how you can look
relook at
and replay judgment calls uh everybody's
judgment is going to be a little
different that's why you hire officials
they make the call on the spot and you
live with it we've had that for 100
years
and then to say well we're going to fix
someone's judgment
by somebody else's judgment just didn't
make any sense to me
the fourth and 15 so no on-side kick so
now we're towing with fourth and 15
for the team that would be trying the
on-side kick your thoughts with that
strategy
yeah i'm not a fan of that because to me
now you're replacing the skill of my
kicker for the skill of my quarterback
and to me
kickoff should be a special teams play
and now we're saying
uh it's almost like two-point conversion
okay
you know you can get two points we make
it difficult so i i guess the
thought is there but to me you you when
you're kicking the ball off you should
have to kick it off
and your kicker should have to have some
skill i understand the safety aspect of
it
uh but now we're just making the
quarterbacks more
uh important but if we're concerned
about safety
the onside kick doesn't have more key
players you have
now i got to put my offense and defense
back on the field for a fourth and 15.
so so now i have the star players
you know further at risk with a a play
like this instead of the onside kick
right to me if you're worried about
safety and kickoffs are dangerous then
take kickoffs out of everything just
start the ball at the 30-yard line
uh when the the offense gets it now i'd
be more
in favor of this fourth and 15th play uh
hey i can give the
offense the ball at the 30-yard line or
i can have a fourth and 15 from my own
20
and i'll take my chances every time out
but don't have it be a special teams
play
part of the time until it really gets
critical and then turn it into an
offensive play i see right through you
though coach you're being phony because
this comes down to devin hester and you
just don't want
devin hester kickoffs are very dangerous
there's a lot of danger
but do you realize devin hester would
not be a
borderline hall of famer in today's game
because we're trying to get the kickoff
out of the game
all these great return men who made
names for themselves
we won't have that anymore in the nfl
and that's hard to take
such an exciting part of it and to see
those guys who could
could go the distance and you had to
plan for them and you're trying to kick
away from them and kick to the corners
and squib and all those things
to me that was an interesting part of
the game and knowing
that devin hester every time back there
had a chance to take it to the house
people were watching now kickoffs
basically you go get your
coffee or your your snack and wait for
them to spot the ball
i'm also curious about these
quarterbacks this year in particular
trying to get
acclimated with an offense i know tom
brady is doing that he's going to have
well it'll be a challenge i guess trying
to get your players together but
here you have joe burrow is expected to
play this year i don't know if tua
is going to play or justin herbert or
jordan love but if you're looking at joe
burrow trying to get acclimated
with a cincinnati offense that needs
help and you can't even do it
you have to do it by you know zoom how
difficult is that going to be and what
is the expectation level for joe burrow
this year
very very tough uh i you know tom brady
his whole thing is timing anticipation
and he's got to find that with these
receivers joe burrow has to find all
that too but then he's got to learn the
often
and he's got to be involved with the
offensive coordinator and everyone
so it's going to really really be
difficult i think in the last 10 years
the offenses have really had an
advantage you know they could go to
arizona or peyton manning could take his
whole crew to duke
and they they could be together and
basically
practice for a week two weeks if they
wanted to
defenses couldn't do that and so the
offenses you saw just get better and
better and really get ahead of the
defenses
now i think it's definitely going to
even up because it's going to be tougher
for the quarterbacks
yeah i don't know if justin herbert
plays this year and if
tua is going to be challenging you know
ryan fitzpatrick i don't even know if
that makes sense for them
but i do think joe burrow is coming in
and they expect him to start right away
yeah he's got to play and he will play
and he'll work his way through it he
just won't be as far along
as he could have been and you know that
that's going to be tough on him but
he'll he'll make his way through it uh i
i appreciated your comments on the
rooney rule
um that it just it felt like they were
trying to do something
and incentivize these owners to do
something that they should be doing
anyway
and these other you know head coaches
and things so um
yeah that was actually really put
forward by steve bashady
and the and the ravens and he just felt
like
that there needed to be something to
kick-start this that we just can't keep
going and i applaud that
uh the one thing i don't think they
really thought through was all the
ramifications of it
and if i'm a coach who gets hired
i don't want people feeling like they
have to help me
and that would have been the case with
these extra draft choices
um you know i got the job and now i'm
going to get extra draft choices
that wasn't the intention but that's the
way it would have come off and i think
that would have been difficult
but you waited a while you certainly had
success
as a defensive coordinator you you put
in your time
but do you think that process could have
been sped up
for you to get a head coaching job yeah
i think there were a lot of owners who
were
looking for a certain type of coach and
not everybody thought that my type of
coach could be successful some of it may
have had to do with race some of it
might have been my
personality uh who knows but i think
that unknown
is different i'm the same person that i
was
25 years ago i could get a job much
easier today
even though i'm not as qualified i've
been out of the game 12 years
but being known to these owners makes a
difference and somehow we've got to get
them to understand that the unknown is
not all bad and there might be some
some quality gems that are unknown to
them if they investigate a little bit
yeah i just was curious about eric b
enemy because if
matt nagy is qualified for a job then
why isn't eric the enemy and
and i'm not i don't mean to single out
naggy but
i got a guy who just came off a super
bowl with one of the great offenses
we've seen
in recent memory and why he didn't get a
head coaching job
i'm not sure yeah well it's not new dan
30 years ago the same thing happened
mike holmgren gets on this great
run with green bay mike holmgren is
orchestrating that offense
everybody who goes into the offensive
coordinator position
moves on and benefits from it um you
know
steve mariucci andy reed they get there
they go on they do a great job sherman
lewis
then becomes the guy who gets elevated
and all of a sudden everybody says well
sherman lewis doesn't call the plays
well gosh neither did steve mariucci
neither did andy reid
that's the way the system worked fast
forward 25
years later same thing doug peterson
frank wright
all these guys in the andy reed system
they're doing the same thing matt and
aggie and they go on they win super
bowls they go on to become coach of the
year
now eric gets in the same position does
the same thing goes to the super bowl as
the offensive coordinator
and well eric the enemy doesn't call the
plays
come on please we haven't moved too far
on this tony
no no i i don't know how
it has to bum you out like you you were
successful you're a hall of fame coach
but you got to be looking and you opened
up doors for a lot of people but you got
to look around and go
it's two steps forward it's two steps
back
well and then that's what really bums me
out i hear these arguments about the
pipeline that we don't have enough
candidates in the pipeline
uh when i coached in 1996
i would specifically looking for young
guys who
were going to rise up the ladder and
they weren't hard to find
okay lovely smith and mike tomlin i got
criticized quite a bit for hiring these
young
unknown guys but if you looked around
you got good recommendation from people
you knew they were going to be good
so uh for me to just sit there and say
there's not a pipeline now we can't find
these guys there's no more leslie
fraziers and mike tomlins and lovey
smiths and jim caldwell i just don't
believe that
well you got to keep keep shouting from
the mountaintop stone which i know
you're not afraid to do but um hey my
best to you
and uh the family and it's always great
to talk to you
thank you i miss you guys got to get up
there soon hopefully we can do it live
one of these days
don't bring in all the kids though tony
no
no we gotta stay in groups of less than
ten
thank you tony alrighty we'll see you
tony dungey hall of famer